This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantal. It's one of the most famous scenes in the Harry Potter series. Two lines of kids newly arrived at the Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and Wizardry, march into a vast and glorious dining hall. The air glows with light from hanging torches and graceful flying candles. The ceiling looks like the night sky, full of stars. The endless dining tables glitter with silver plates and golden goblets. Young students
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《哈利·波特》系列中最著名的场景之一。两排刚抵达霍格沃茨魔法学校的孩子们，走进了一个宏伟壮丽的餐厅。空气中闪烁着悬挂的火把和优雅飞舞的蜡烛发出的光芒。天花板看起来就像布满繁星的夜空。无尽的餐桌上摆满了闪闪发光的银盘和金杯。年轻的学生们
make their way to the front of the hall where an old and crumpled wizards hat awaits them. It is the sorting hat. When I call your name, you will come forth. I shall place the sorting hat on your head and you will be sorted into your houses. The hat peers into the minds of the youngsters. After judging their personality traits and potential, it decides which house they'll belong to during their Hogwarts education. Will it be brave, griffin' door, gentle, huffle puff, smart raven claw, or Not slithering. Not slithering.
走向大厅前方，那里有一顶又旧又皱的巫师帽在等着他们。这就是分院帽。当我叫到你的名字时，你就会走上前来。我会把分院帽戴在你的头上，你就会被分到你的学院。这顶帽子会窥探年轻人的内心。在评判了他们的性格特征和潜力后，它会决定他们在霍格沃茨求学期间属于哪个学院。是勇敢的格兰芬多，温和的赫奇帕奇，聪明的拉文克劳，还是……不是斯莱特林。不是斯莱特林。
Not slithering, eh? Are you sure? You could be great to know. It's all here in your head. And slithering will help you on the way to greatness. Said no doubt about that. No. Well, if you're sure.
不是斯莱特林，嗯？你确定吗？你本可以成就一番伟业。这一切都在你的脑海里。而斯莱特林会助你走向伟大。这一点毫无疑问。不。好吧，如果你确定的话。
Better be... GRIFFENDOR! There is something deeply appealing about the sorting hat. It's wise, it knows people better than they know themselves. It tells them who they are and to which tribe they belong. Are they courageous, loyal, curious, or cunning? All humans, old and young, love this kind of insight. Hi, my name is Michaela Blackburn, and the house I'm in is in Gryffindor.
最好是……格兰芬多！分院帽有一种深深的吸引力。它很睿智，它比人们自己更了解他们。它告诉他们是谁，以及他们属于哪个部落。他们是勇敢、忠诚、好奇还是狡猾？所有的人，无论老少，都喜欢这种洞察力。嗨，我叫米凯拉·布莱克本，我所在的学院是格兰芬多。
I ran into 10-year-old Michaela and a group of her friends at Potterverse, a Harry Potter convention in Baltimore. I'm Haley and I'm in Ravenclaw. I'm Lily and I'm Angra from Dore. I'm Riley and I'm in Ravenclaw. I'd come to the conference to learn more about the Hogwarts houses and the appeal of the
我在巴尔的摩举行的哈利·波特大会“Potterverse”上遇到了10岁的米凯拉和她的一群朋友。我是海莉，我在拉文克劳。我是莉莉，我在格兰芬多。我是莱利，我在拉文克劳。我来到这次会议是为了更多地了解霍格沃茨学院以及
sorting hat. Michaela and her friends are huge Harry Potter friends. And do you all know each other really well? Yeah! Okay good. Alright so here's a little test that I want to do, okay? We're gonna pick Michaela and you're not gonna say it but the rest of your friends on the count of three are gonna call out and say what house you think she should be in. Not what she says she's in or what she wants to be in but based on what you know of her what house you think she should be in all right so the count of three ready
分院帽的吸引力。米凯拉和她的朋友们都是哈利·波特的超级粉丝。你们彼此都很了解吗？是的！好的，太好了。好吧，我想做一个小测试，好吗？我们要选米凯拉，你先别说，但你的朋友们在数到三的时候要大声说出他们认为你应该去哪个学院。不是说她自己说的或她想去的，而是根据你们对她的了解，你们认为她应该去哪个学院，好了，数到三，准备
one two three and what had you said I said I wasn't different to her your friends got you completely wrong I wanted this camp and it sorted me into slithering but I am sort of cunning. So yeah, so yeah, they're right, and she's right as well, because I am sort of nice. Yes, you are loyal to your friends, I would think. Yeah. Why do you think she's a Slytherin? Because me and her went to a camp,
一、二、三，你们说了什么？我说我跟她不一样。你的朋友们完全搞错了。我参加了这个夏令营，它把我分到了斯莱特林，但我确实有点狡猾。所以，是的，他们是对的，她也对，因为我确实有点友善。是的，我想你对朋友很忠诚。是的。为什么你认为她是斯莱特林？因为我和她去了一个夏令营，
and we got a Harry Potter camp called Hobwards, and we got sorted into Slytherin, and I got Ravenclaw. And why did you think she sorted into Slytherin and I got Ravenclaw. And why did you think she was a Slytherin? Because my sister is actually a Slytherin and she kind of has the same personality as my sister. Even among these young girls, it's easy to see how the question, what house are you in, flows into a larger question. What kind of person are you? Your Hogwarts house is a window into your identity. Walking around the convention, I met Brittany Overman and Devon Valverde. Alright, well we met on a social media app.
我们参加了一个叫“霍格沃茨”的哈利·波特夏令营，我们被分到了斯莱特林，而我被分到了拉文克劳。为什么你认为她被分到了斯莱特林？因为我姐姐其实就是斯莱特林，她和我姐姐的性格有点像。即使在这些小女孩中间，也很容易看出“你属于哪个学院”这个问题是如何演变成一个更大的问题的。你是什么样的人？你的霍格沃茨学院是你身份的一扇窗。在大会上走动时，我遇到了布列塔尼·奥弗曼和德文·瓦尔韦德。好吧，我们在一个社交媒体应用上认识的。
Brittany spotted a line on Devon's profile that she liked. It said, talk Harry Potter to me. She responded with the inevitable question. What's your Hogwarts house? She actually helped me discover my house. I was with her when I discovered that I'm a Hufflepuff. Yeah, and I'm a slither and so it's actually a very unlikely pairing, but it's a very sweet one.
布列塔尼在德文的个人资料上发现了一行她喜欢的字。上面写着：跟我聊聊哈利·波特。她用那个不可避免的问题回应了。你的霍格沃茨学院是哪个？她实际上帮我发现了我的学院。我和她在一起时，发现我是赫奇帕奇。是的，我是斯莱特林，所以这其实是一个非常不可能的组合，但非常甜蜜。
Got it. And what was the social media website? It's a little embarrassing, but it was Tinder. Yeah. It's an Apple TV. Who knew, right? So wait, you're on Tinder and someone says talk Harry Potter to me. That's what happened. Oh my god, but it was like the best thing ever because obviously people on Tinder don't look for people to talk about Harry Potter and I was like
明白了。那个社交媒体网站是什么？有点尴尬，是Tinder。是的。它是Apple TV。谁知道呢，对吧？等等，你在Tinder上，有人对你说“跟我聊聊哈利·波特”。事情就是这样。天哪，但这简直是最好的事情，因为显然Tinder上的人不会找人聊哈利·波特，我当时
really worried because I initially did not want to join the app at all just because I was like I know what people look for on there and I was like that's not what I'm looking for but I know that there's a lot of people on there so it's like chances are I might find somebody who doesn't want what's usually asked for on Tinder so like I saw the Harry Potter thing I was like okay I got it trying to talk to him hopefully he talks back to me and it worked out pretty well. The desire to find our tribe is universal. We do it all the time. If it's not Hogwarts houses then it's whether we are night people or morning people, dog people or cat people,
真的很担心，因为我起初根本不想加入这个应用，只是因为我知道人们在上面找什么，我当时想那不是我在找的，但我知道上面有很多很多人，所以很有可能我会找到一个不想找通常在Tinder上找的东西的人，所以我看到了哈利·波特的东西，我就想，好吧，我得试着跟他聊聊，希望他能回我，结果还挺顺利的。寻找我们部落的渴望是普遍的。我们一直在这样做。如果不是霍格沃茨学院，那就是我们是夜猫子还是早起鸟，是爱狗人士还是爱猫人士，
Aquarius or Leo. Hi, I'm the star goddess and here is how to spot a Leo. You can spot a Leo because they're right in the center of the room standing there. You're a dog person. Okay, dog people are way better than cats. I'm flowing here like Bill Clinton and Monica Lewinsky. This is going to be country versus city. The dog people are conformists.
是水瓶座还是狮子座。嗨，我是星座女神，这是识别狮子座的方法。你可以认出狮子座，因为他们就站在房间的正中央。你是爱狗人士。好吧，爱狗人士比爱猫人士好多了。我在这里就像比尔·克林顿和莫妮卡·莱温斯基一样滔滔不绝。这将会是乡村与城市的对决。爱狗人士是墨守成规的人。
I was actually born in the city. And so it goes. People, on the other hand, are more abstract. All these categories, just like Hogwarts houses, offer insight into why we behave the way we do. They offer us guidance on how to navigate a complex world. This need to understand ourselves as fostered a thriving industry built on the marketing and sale of personality tests.
我其实是在城市出生的。事情就是这样。另一方面，人们更抽象。所有这些分类，就像霍格沃茨学院一样，提供了关于我们为什么会有这种行为的洞察。它们为我们如何驾驭复杂的世界提供了指导。这种理解我们自己的需求催生了一个蓬勃发展的行业，建立在性格测试的营销和销售之上。
These tests promise to tell you who you are, why you are the way you are, and what it all means. Some of these tests are long, some are short, some are free, some cost a lot of money, some categorize you by your favorite color. And today, you'll discover your true colors, the unique combination of traits that make up your personality. If you like to be prepared, according to the True Colors test, you must be a gold. Innovative people are green and blues. Blues pay attention to their emotions, and one of their favorites is romance.
这些测试承诺告诉你你是谁，你为什么会是现在这样，以及这一切意味着什么。有些测试很长，有些很短，有些免费，有些很贵，有些根据你最喜欢的颜色对你进行分类。今天，你将发现你真正的色彩，构成你个性的独特特征组合。如果你喜欢做好准备，根据“真实色彩”测试，你一定是金色。创新型的人是绿色和蓝色。蓝色的人关注他们的情绪，他们最喜欢的主题之一是浪漫。
There are personality tests that promise to match you with the perfect job. Others promise that discovering your personality will guide you to love. Ever hear of the term hopeless romantic? Never wonder if it happens to describe you? Well, welcome to It's All Viral. And today, we're going to be seeing if you are indeed a hopeless romantic. There are even personality tests to help you shed weight. There is some new research in the book out that says the keys are losing weight,
有些性格测试承诺为你匹配完美的工作。另一些则承诺发现你的性格会引导你找到爱情。听说过“无可救药的浪漫主义者”这个词吗？有没有想过它是否正好描述了你？好吧，欢迎来到“一切皆病毒”。今天，我们要看看你是否真的是一个无可救药的浪漫主义者。甚至还有帮助你减肥的性格测试。有一本新书中的研究说，减肥的关键是
is avoiding the foods that clash with your personality type? Help the people to think about that. These tests may seem silly, but there's something unsettling about them. They make me uneasy because there's been a long history of classifying people by their personalities. This history hasn't always been as benign as labeling someone a hopeless romantic. There was a time when scientists would openly, without any discomfort, classify people's personality by their race. Asians were meek or awkward, Europeans were ambitious and brave,
避免那些与你的性格类型相冲突的食物？帮人们思考一下。这些测试看起来很傻，但它们有一些令人不安的地方。它们让我感到不安，因为历史上一直有根据性格对人进行分类的长期记录。这段历史并不总是像给某人贴上“无可救药的浪漫主义者”标签那样无害。曾几何时，科学家们会公开地、毫无顾忌地根据种族对人的性格进行分类。亚洲人是温顺或笨拙的，欧洲人是雄心勃勃和勇敢的，
Africans, wild and animalistic. Or think about the associations people have long had about gender. Men's personalities are supposed to be dominant. Women submissive. There's a reason many of us feel horror today about personality classifications that were once considered scientific. We recognize now that they were just simply racist or sexist. As we fought to eliminate these old systems, why is it we keep coming up with new ways
非洲人是野蛮和动物性的。或者想想人们长期以来对性别的联想。男性的性格应该是主导的。女性应该是顺从的。我们今天对曾经被认为是科学的性格分类感到恐惧是有原因的。我们现在认识到，它们仅仅是种族主义或性别歧视。当我们努力消除这些旧系统时，为什么我们还在不断想出新的方法
to classify ourselves? For one thing, there's something enormously seductive about such tests, they offer quick and easy insights into the messy and complicated problems we face every day. And as I heard at the part of our convention, classifying people can be a source of joy. So let's paint this with her now on a count of three, one, two, three. Slurring. But as fun as they can be, personality tests can also lead to serious outcomes.
来对我们自己进行分类？首先，这类测试有一种巨大的诱惑力，它们为我们每天面临的混乱和复杂的问题提供了快速而简单的见解。正如我在大会上听到的那样，对人进行分类可以是一种快乐的源泉。所以，让我们在数到三的时候给米凯拉贴上标签，一、二、三。斯莱特林。但尽管它们很有趣，性格测试也可能导致严重的后果。
Many corporations today are using such tests to make important decisions. When we ask listeners to share their experiences of personality testing in the workplace, we got a huge response. The most famous of these workplace personality tests is the Myers Briggs type indicator, or the MBTI. It sorts people into 16 personality types and it's hugely popular. It's used by most of America's Fortune 100 companies and some 2 million people take the test each year. The test categorizes you along four axes. Each describes a way of seeing or dealing with a world. For example,
许多公司今天都在使用这些测试来做出重要的决定。当我们要求听众分享他们在工作场所进行性格测试的经历时，我们得到了巨大的反响。这些工作场所性格测试中最著名的是迈尔斯-布里格斯类型指标，即MBTI。它将人分为16种性格类型，非常受欢迎。美国财富100强公司中的大多数都在使用它，每年约有200万人参加该测试。该测试根据四个轴线对你进行分类。每一个都描述了一种看待或处理世界的方式。例如，
if you're an ENFP, that means you're an extrovert, rather than an introvert, you rely on intuition more than facts, you're emotional rather than cerebral, and you prefer to go with the flow, rather than have a highly structured life. We had lots of people calling about the Myers-Briggs, many praised the test for helping to improve their lives. Some said it helped them find love. I took the personality test as part of a Christian club that I was in as an undergraduate in college and discovered that I am what Myers-Briggs calls an ENFP. This is listener Haley Jones. She says she didn't think much about her Myers-Briggs category
如果你是ENFP，这意味着你是外向的，而不是内向的，你更多地依赖直觉而不是事实，你是感性的而不是理性的，你更喜欢顺其自然，而不是过着高度结构化的生活。我们有很多关于迈尔斯-布里格斯的电话，许多人称赞该测试帮助改善了他们的生活。有些人说它帮助他们找到了爱情。我在大学本科时参加了一个基督教俱乐部，作为其中的一部分，我参加了性格测试，发现我是迈尔斯-布里格斯所说的ENFP。这是听众海莉·琼斯。她说她并没有太在意她的迈尔斯-布里格斯类别
until she made a discovery. The last three guys who I dated had all had the same Myers-Briggs type indicator. They were all INTJs. Once she realized this, she began to use this pattern as a screening tool. The end, I absolutely look for them. It's one of the first questions I ask people, and on all my dating profiles it says, ENFP seeks INTJ. Then I know that that sounds kind of funny,
直到她有一个发现。我约会的最后三个男人都有相同的迈尔斯-布里格斯类型指标。他们都是INTJ。一旦她意识到这一点，她就开始把这种模式作为一种筛选工具。最后，我绝对会寻找他们。这是我问人们的第一个问题之一，在我所有的约会资料上都写着：ENFP寻找INTJ。我知道这听起来有点好笑，
but it's just been true for me. Ali Adler took the Myers-Briggs during a hard time in her career. She was 26 and miserable in her job. The test told her that she was an ENFJ. This was a surprise because Allie didn't think of herself as driven by emotion. But she soon began to see things about herself that told her the test was right. And it really helped me understand myself in a way that I hadn't understood myself before,
但这对我来说确实是真的。艾莉·阿德勒在职业生涯的困难时期参加了迈尔斯-布里格斯测试。她当时26岁，对自己的工作感到痛苦。测试告诉她，她是ENFJ。这很令人惊讶，因为艾莉并不认为自己是由情绪驱动的。但她很快开始看到关于自己的事情，告诉她测试是正确的。它确实帮助我以一种我以前从未理解过的方式理解了自己，
so that I could work around and manage challenges both in my personal and my professional life related to the emotionally feelings driven person and part of my personality that I hadn't really acknowledged before and it turns out is really central to who I am. So learning about my personality type has actually been, I think, critical to my happiness and my success since then, and I am really glad I did it. Some listeners said that test results had even shaped their very identity. In college my best friend and I both took the Myers-Briggs personality test and we both wound up getting ENFP. This is Christina Healy. And we both were just so excited about it.
这样我就可以在个人和职业生活中围绕并管理挑战，这些挑战与我性格中情感驱动的部分有关，我以前并没有真正承认过，结果发现它确实是我核心的一部分。所以了解我的性格类型实际上是，我认为，对我从那以后的幸福和成功至关重要，我真的很高兴我做了它。一些听众说，测试结果甚至塑造了他们的身份。在大学里，我和我最好的朋友都参加了迈尔斯-布里格斯性格测试，我们最终都得到了ENFP。这是克里斯蒂娜·希利。我们都为此感到非常兴奋。
We read the description of what that meant for us and the types of job we were most likely to get and just different personality traits and that really helped solidify a lot of our personality during that time. Christina says those last years of college were an important time of self-discovery. I mean that did a lot of a hard work for us being able to just read and agree with and then therefore live the rest of our lives that way. What Christina is saying is that the test played the role that a friend or a teacher or a mentor might have played. The tests told her, Christina, this is who you are, this is your destiny.
我们阅读了这对我们意味着什么，我们最有可能获得的工作类型，以及不同的性格特征，这确实有助于在那个时期巩固我们的许多性格。克里斯蒂娜说，大学的最后几年是自我发现的重要时期。我的意思是，它为我们做了很多艰苦的工作，能够阅读并同意，然后因此以那种方式度过我们余下的生活。克里斯蒂娜所说的是，测试扮演了朋友、老师或导师可能扮演的角色。测试告诉她，克里斯蒂娜，这就是你是谁，这就是你的命运。
She had a mold and she was happy to shape herself to it. Years later, Christina was asked to take the test again. A lot had happened in her life since she and her roommate learned that they were both ENFPs. She had gone to graduate school, relocated to a new city, matured. She'd changed and she worried how Myers-Briggs category would change too. She didn't want that, so when she retook the test, she made sure to give answers that would allow her to remain an ENFP. She'd found her tribe. She didn't want to be kicked out.
她有一个模子，她很高兴把自己塑造成那个样子。多年后，克里斯蒂娜被要求再次参加测试。自从她和室友得知她们都是ENFP以来，她的生活中发生了很多事情。她读了研究生，搬到了一个新的城市，成熟了。她变了，她担心迈尔斯-布里格斯的类别也会改变。她不想要那样，所以当她重考时，她确保给出的答案能让她保持ENFP。她找到了她的部落。她不想被踢出去。
For all those who love the Myers-Briggs and other personality tests, there are plenty of people who don't. They feel that rather than helping, these tests can be deeply destructive. I started feeling like Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde, like there was this person that would come out and I had no idea that it was there. When we come back, we look at how personality tests are being used for more than dating advice and career counseling. Increasingly, they have turned into a tool to decide who should do what in the workplace,
对于所有那些热爱迈尔斯-布里格斯和其他性格测试的人来说，也有很多人不喜欢它们。他们觉得这些测试不仅没有帮助，反而可能具有极大的破坏性。我开始觉得自己像杰基尔博士和海德先生，好像有这样一个人会出来，而我根本不知道它的存在。当我们回来时，我们将看看性格测试是如何被用于约会建议和职业咨询之外的用途的。它们越来越多地变成了一种决定工作场所谁该做什么的工具，
who should get a promotion? Who should get fired? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Stay with us. This is NPR. I'm Shankar Vedantam. You're listening to Hidden Brain. Today we're talking about the power of personality tests. These tools tap into a deep desire we have to discover our place in the world. For some people, they offer comfort and relief. But that's not always the case. Hello Hidden Brain friends.
谁该获得晋升？谁该被解雇？你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。请留下来。这是NPR。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。今天我们正在谈论性格测试的力量。这些工具利用了我们发现自己在世界上位置的深层渴望。对一些人来说，它们提供了安慰和解脱。但情况并非总是如此。你好，《Hidden Brain》的朋友们。
My name is Matthew. I am in Westminster, Colorado. And my experience with Myers-Briggs played no small part in destroying my life, ruining me emotionally for years. Matthew Gail says that after being promoted to technical director at a theater he worked at, he and other managers went on an overnight retreat. Among other team building activities, they all took the Myers-Briggs. And now my job required that I be organized and have ideas and do math and all these sort of technical and intellectual things.
我叫马修。我在科罗拉多州的威斯敏斯特。我对迈尔斯-布里格斯的经历在摧毁我的生活、在情感上摧毁我多年方面起了不小的作用。马修·盖尔说，在被提升为他工作的剧院的技术总监后，他和经理们去参加了一个过夜的静修会。在团队建设活动中，他们都参加了迈尔斯-布里格斯测试。现在我的工作要求我组织有序，有想法，做数学，以及所有这些技术和智力方面的事情。
And when we did the Myers-Briggs, I came out to be like this INFJ. out to be like this INFJ. I was mystic and quiet and so after that, after that moment, anytime I made a mistake or I said something or had an idea, either my coworkers or myself would say, but that's just because you're this personality type. Maybe there's a job better suited to your personality type. And it made it so people didn't trust my opinion, didn't trust my ideas, didn't trust my conclusion, didn't trust what any action that I took throughout the day.
当我们做迈尔斯-布里格斯测试时，我出来是像INFJ这样的人。我是神秘而安静的，所以在那之后，在那一刻之后，每当我犯错或说了什么或有了想法时，我的同事或我自己就会说，但那只是因为你是这种性格类型。也许有更适合你性格类型的工作。这使得人们不信任我的意见，不信任我的想法，不信任我的结论，不信任我全天采取的任何行动。
Matthew began to doubt his own skills. I thought I was the sort of organized and logical person. And I started feeling like Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde like there was this person that would come out. And I had no idea that it was there. That I was really this artsy, fartsy head in the clouds guy who couldn't get anything done, who really just needed to have a pottery studio
马修开始怀疑自己的技能。我以为我是那种有组织和逻辑的人。我开始觉得自己像杰基尔博士和海德先生，好像有这样一个人会出来。而我根本不知道它的存在。我真的是那种艺术的、虚伪的、头脑在云端的家伙，什么都做不成，真的只需要有一个陶艺工作室
and sit around some pot all day. That's kind of how people were treating me. Matthew says his colleague stopped trusting him and he stopped trusting himself. A veterinarian I spoke with also felt that the personality test she took at work had gotten her completely wrong. Cynthia works for a private animal emergency hotline. We're not using her last name or the name of her company to protect her privacy.
整天坐在那里玩陶土。人们就是这样对待我的。马修说他的同事不再信任他，他也停止了信任自己。我采访的一位兽医也觉得她在工作中参加的性格测试完全搞错了。辛西娅为一家私人动物紧急热线工作。为了保护她的隐私，我们不使用她的姓氏或她公司的名称。
Cynthia says her job is very stressful. Often people call in panic. She remembers one call from a person whose labored or retriever had eaten rat poison. The owner was really, really anxious. The dog had just gotten into it five minutes earlier. And they all, when they're really anxious, they say, usually at the end, is my dog going to die. Often, Cynthia takes 30 calls like this from around the country in an eight hour shift.
辛西娅说她的工作压力很大。人们经常惊慌失措地打电话来。她记得有一个人打来的电话，那人的拉布拉多猎犬吃了老鼠药。主人真的非常焦虑。狗在五分钟前刚吃了它。当他们非常焦虑时，他们通常在最后说，我的狗会死吗。通常，辛西娅在八小时的轮班中会接到30个这样的电话。
It's work that requires a combination of knowledge and patience and empathy. Synthiana colleagues rely on one another for support. We're all very conscientious of each other. We have a good group there. We don't have any scheduled breaks when we're at work. We only take breaks when it's not too busy and the other person isn't going to be swamped by too many calls.
这是一项需要知识、耐心和同理心结合的工作。辛西娅和同事们互相依靠支持。我们都非常体谅彼此。我们那里有一个很好的团队。我们在工作时没有任何预定的休息时间。我们只在不太忙且其他人不会被太多的电话淹没时才休息。
We are just very considerate of each other and everybody in the team tends to be real good, hard workers and considerate of each other that way. To Cynthia, it was obvious her team was good at what it did, but she says that didn't stop the company's human resources department from conducting personality tests to draw out deeper truths about the employees. Our company, which is a smaller company, was purchased by another company, and the HR department for the larger company sent an email out to all of us in the new company asking us just to do a personality test.
我们只是非常体谅彼此，团队中的每个人往往都是非常好、努力工作且以这种方式体谅彼此的人。对辛西娅来说，很明显她的团队擅长他们所做的事情，但她说这并没有阻止公司的人力资源部门进行性格测试，以挖掘员工更深层的真相。我们的公司，是一家较小的公司，被另一家公司收购了，大公司的人力资源部门给我们新公司的所有人发了一封电子邮件，要求我们做一个性格测试。
And they said the reason they wanted us to do it was just to help our managers better manage us. Cynthia says she and her colleagues were in a bind. We were concerned that if we refused to do it, that maybe, I don't know, maybe they would fire us or something like that. And they were sending out a number of reminders to do the test. So she took it. The test was called the Culture Index. It was very short. On the first page, Cynthia was asked to pick adjectives that described her. On the second page, she
他们说他们想让我们做这个的原因只是为了帮助我们的经理更好地管理我们。辛西娅说她和同事们陷入了困境。我们担心如果我们拒绝做，也许，我不知道，也许他们会解雇我们之类的。他们一直在发送许多提醒去做测试。所以她做了。这个测试叫“文化指数”。它非常短。在第一页，辛西娅被要求选择描述她的形容词。在第二页，她
had to pick adjectives that described her on the job. That was it. What kind of words were they on these two, when you saw the pages describe the test to me? Yeah, so the words were things like calm, patient, knowledgeable, logical, friendly, outgoing, attractive. Cynthia remembers speaking words that she felt reflected who she was. Calm, patient, resourceful, logical, friendly. A couple days later, she says, HR emailed her the results. They rated people in seven categories. Autonomy, social ability, pace, conformity,
必须选择描述她在工作中的形容词。就是这样。这些词是什么样的，当你看到页面时，向我描述一下测试？是的，这些词是像冷静、耐心、知识渊博、逻辑性强、友好、外向、有吸引力之类的。辛西娅记得选择了她觉得反映了她是谁的词。冷静、耐心、足智多谋、逻辑性强、友好。几天后，她说，人力资源部通过电子邮件把结果发给了她。他们将人分为七个类别。自主性、社交能力、节奏、一致性、
logic, ingenuity, and energy units. Most of the scales ran from 1 to 10 with 10 being the best. Cynthia learned she'd scored a 1 for all the categories, except energy. That category had a maximum score of 100. She got 12. Then there's a write-up. So they have a graph when you get your results, so there's two very scientific-looking graphs and then they have a write-up. And the write-up for me said, let's see how my chance is.
逻辑、独创性和能量单位。大多数量表从1到10，10是最好的。辛西娅得知她在所有类别中都得了1分，除了能量。该类别的最高分是100。她得了12分。然后有一份书面报告。所以当你得到结果时，他们有一个图表，所以有两个看起来非常科学的图表，然后他们有一份书面报告。我的书面报告说，让我们看看我的机会。
It says, this individual has very little energy and may require more breaks during the workday than most individuals. And most people, a lot of my co-workers, got kind of similar comments. Some not quite as severe as some said, this person runs out of energy by the afternoon and will need breaks in the afternoon. So, what was your interpretation when the energy scale runs from 2 to 100 and you were rated at 12? What was your reaction to that? Oh I thought it was ridiculous. Like I had no idea how they calculated that and it really is of all the things that they said about me that is the most blatantly
上面写着，这个人的能量很少，可能比大多数人需要更多的休息时间。大多数人，我的很多同事，都得到了类似的评论。有些不像有些那么严重，说这个人下午就没能量了，下午需要休息。那么，当能量量表从2到100，而你被评为12时，你的解读是什么？你对此有什么反应？哦，我觉得这很荒谬。就像我根本不知道他们是怎么计算出来的，而且在他们说的关于我的所有事情中，这确实是最公然的
wrong and anybody who knows me would actually know that's true. I mean the things that they said about me, that is the most blatantly wrong. And anybody who knows me would actually know that's true. I mean, honestly, I think if you make it through veterinary school, you have to have a certain amount of energy. And I just always work very hard and I always have. It's really been kind of the defining characteristic of my life, I would say. Cynthia says the experience felt insulting. So I looked into the test honestly, it was my reaction. I had gone into it assuming that it was an accepted test by the psychological community.
错误的，任何认识我的人实际上都知道这是真的。我的意思是他们说的关于我的事情，那是最公然错误的。而且任何认识我的人实际上都知道这是真的。我的意思是，老实说，我认为如果你能通过兽医学校，你必须有一定的能量。我一直工作非常努力，我一直都是这样。我想这确实是我生活中定义性的特征。辛西娅说这种经历让人感到侮辱。所以我老实地研究了这个测试，这是我的反应。我假设它是一个被心理学界接受的测试。
And then when I looked into it, I saw that they have no peer-reviewed published data at all and actually they don't call themselves a test, they insist on calling themselves a personality survey, so I just couldn't couldn't believe that any company would put any validity to this. Gary Wallstrom is the founder of the Culture Index, the test at Cynthia Doak. He declined to do a recorded interview but spoke to us by phone. He says that Cynthia, quote, doesn't know what she's talking about. Gary's not a psychologist, but says the survey was developed in consultation with a psychology professor. He agreed that the culture index has not been through a scientific peer review process, but he has confidence
然后当我研究它时，我看到他们根本没有任何同行评审的发表数据，实际上他们不称自己为测试，他们坚持称自己为性格调查，所以我简直不敢相信任何公司会对此给予任何有效性。加里·沃尔斯特罗姆是辛西娅参加的“文化指数”测试的创始人。他拒绝接受录音采访，但通过电话与我们交谈。他说辛西娅，“不知道她在说什么”。加里不是心理学家，但说该调查是在咨询一位心理学教授的情况下开发的。他承认文化指数没有经过科学的同行评审过程，但他有信心
that it helps companies manage and motivate people based on their personality. He says it helps with hiring decisions. It allows managers to make sure the personality of the individual fits the personality of the position. The Culture Index is one of many personality assessments that companies can choose from. As advertising and infomercials make abundantly clear. For most of the positions we create,
它能帮助公司根据员工的性格来管理和激励他们。他说它有助于招聘决策。它允许经理确保个人的性格符合职位的性格。文化指数是公司可以选择的众多性格评估之一。正如广告和电视购物节目所清楚表明的那样。对于我们创造的大多数职位，
they're being used all the time in important decisions. So instead of me attracting 100 people for one job, I'm going to get 50. There will be naturally more successful in that specific role. So, in fact, job applicants are so aware of how seriously companies take these tests that services have popped up to tell people how to hack the tests. We searched YouTube and found homegrown videos like this one. Let us go through a couple of examples through or false questions. Despite the poor audio quality, this video, how to pass a pre-employment personality test,
它们一直在重要的决策中使用。所以，与其让我为一个职位吸引100个人，我将得到50个。他们在那个特定的角色中会自然地更成功。因此，实际上，求职者非常清楚公司对这些测试的重视程度，以至于出现了告诉人们如何破解测试的服务。我们在YouTube上搜索并找到了像这样的自制视频。让我们通过几个例子来做真或假的问题。尽管音频质量很差，但这个视频，“如何通过入职前性格测试”，
has racked up nearly 300,000 views. I always love to be in large noisy crowds. You may not always like to be in large noisy crowds, so you might answer false. What they are really asking is whether or not you like people and can deal with it at work when it is busy. That makes the answer true. Most companies use the Myers-Briggs, which is widely considered to be an industry standard.
已经获得了近30万次观看。我总是喜欢在拥挤嘈杂的人群中。你可能并不总是喜欢在拥挤嘈杂的人群中，所以你可能会回答假。他们真正问的是你是否喜欢人，并且在工作忙碌时能否应付。这使得答案为真。大多数公司使用迈尔斯-布里格斯，它被广泛认为是行业标准。
This test has an interesting history. It originated in the ideas of a contemporary of Sigmund Freud, Karl Jung. He identified three dimensions of personality. This is Alan Hammer, a psychologist and former chair of the Myers Breaks Foundation. One was, where you tend to focus your attention. And he said that there are two opposite ways you can focus your attention. And one is on the external world. He called that extroversion. And one is on the internal world.
这个测试有一段有趣的历史。它起源于西格蒙德·弗洛伊德的同时代人卡尔·荣格的思想。他确定了三个性格维度。这是艾伦·哈默，一位心理学家，也是迈尔斯-布里格斯基金会的前主席。一个是，你倾向于把注意力集中在哪里。他说有两种相反的方式可以集中你的注意力。一种是外部世界。他称之为外向。一种是内部世界。
And he called that introversion. Category two is about how people perceive the world. Some people focus on details, on facts. Others are more intuitive, imaginative. The third category is whether people are driven by thinking or by emotion. Thinking is a way of objectively looking at a situation, making it the attached objective, logical, analytical decision or judgment about something. Whereas the opposite of that is what he called feeling,
他称之为内向。类别二是关于人们如何感知世界。有些人关注细节，关注事实。另一些人更直觉、更有想象力。第三个类别是人们是由思考还是由情感驱动。思考是一种客观地看待情况、做出分离的、客观的、逻辑的、分析性的决定或判断某事的方式。而它的对立面是他所说的感觉，
the subjective interpersonal way of making a decision. In the 1940s, an American woman named Isabel Myers became interested in Jung's ideas. Her mother actually was interested in Jung first, and then Isabel, who was a housewife at the time and a writer, got interested in type and then started looking at applications in particularly around careers. Isabel Myers, along with her mother, Catherine Cook Briggs, turned Jung's theories into a test. She also added her own ideas into the mix. Isabel Myers added a fourth dimension, which she described as which of those two processes you
一种主观的、人际交往的决策方式。在20世纪40年代，一位名叫伊莎贝尔·迈尔斯的美国女性对荣格的思想产生了兴趣。她的母亲实际上先对荣格感兴趣，然后伊莎贝尔，当时是一位家庭主妇和作家，对类型产生了兴趣，然后开始研究应用，特别是在职业方面。伊莎贝尔·迈尔斯和她的母亲凯瑟琳·库克·布里格斯一起，将荣格的理论变成了一个测试。她还将自己的想法加入其中。伊莎贝尔·迈尔斯增加了第四个维度，她将其描述为那两个过程中的哪一个你
tend to use in the outer world. So she said, you either tend to use a judging function in the outer world or a perceiving function in the outer world. And that's represented by the letters J and P. So those are the four dimensions. And when you combine the four dimensions and the two opposites on each dimension, you get 16 different types. Even though Isabel Myers and her mother was self-taught, many of the researchers who have worked on the test since then are psychologists. Nonetheless, despite the widespread popularity of the Myers-Briggs test, it's generally not held in high regard by top psychologists who study personality.
倾向于在外部世界使用。所以她说，你倾向于在外部世界使用判断功能或感知功能。这由字母J和P表示。所以这就是四个维度。当你结合四个维度和每个维度上的两个对立面时，你会得到16种不同的类型。尽管伊莎贝尔·迈尔斯和她的母亲是自学的，但自那时以来从事该测试工作的许多研究人员都是心理学家。尽管如此，尽管迈尔斯-布里格斯测试非常受欢迎，但它通常不受研究性格的顶级心理学家的重视。
Adam Grant is a professor of psychology and management at the University of Pennsylvania. When he first took the Myers-Briggs, he learned that he was an INTJ. In other words, an introvert, an interpreter, a thinker, and a judge. Fine, he said. But then, a few months later, he took the test again. I got opposite scores on every dimension. I scored, uh, now I was ESFP. Adam says fans of the Myers-Briggs tend to shrug off such discrepancies. Well, they say either, you know, you're gaming the test and you want a different answer. I could not have wanted something more opposite. I wanted consistent. I wanted to know who I was.
亚当·格兰特是宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学和管理学教授。当他第一次参加迈尔斯-布里格斯测试时，他得知自己是INTJ。换句话说，内向、直觉、思考和判断。很好，他说。但几个月后，他又参加了测试。我在每个维度上都得到了相反的分数。我得分，呃，现在我是ESFP。亚当说，迈尔斯-布里格斯的粉丝倾向于对这种差异不屑一顾。好吧，他们说，要么你知道，你在玩弄测试，你想要一个不同的答案。我不可能想要更相反的东西。我想要一致。我想知道我是谁。
I was trying really hard to answer them the same way. I began to question whether this test had any validity and reliability whatsoever. Validity and reliability. These are two of the most important scientific factors to consider when judging the value of any psychological test. Validity indicates the extent to which the test measures what it is supposed to measure. Reliability refers to whether the test produces consistent results when repeated measurements are made. Adam Grant says, the Myers-Briggs comes up short in both areas. It doesn't do very well in reliability or validity. It falls well short of most conventional reliability standards. And the Myers-Briggs proponents themselves will
我非常努力地以同样的方式回答它们。我开始怀疑这个测试是否具有任何有效性和可靠性。有效性和可靠性。在判断任何心理测试的价值时，这是两个最重要的科学因素。有效性表明测试测量其应该测量的程度。可靠性是指当进行重复测量时，测试是否产生一致的结果。亚当·格兰特说，迈尔斯-布里格斯在两个方面都做得不够。它在可靠性或有效性方面表现不佳。它远未达到大多数传统的可靠性标准。而迈尔斯-布里格斯的支持者们自己会
tell you that it doesn't predict anything. The thing that concerns me about personality test is less the stuff that might be inaccurate but is mostly just fun, and more the stuff that is increasingly being used to gauge who should be doing what in the workplace, who is best suited for which career, to select the people who you want to rise within an organization. It's a great way to weed out all kinds of diversity. There was a company in Canada not long ago where there was a major acquisition made and the CEO gave every single person who was acquired the Myers-Briggs and then fired everyone who didn't match this type. Good grief. That's terrifying.
告诉你它不能预测任何事情。关于性格测试，让我担心的是那些可能不准确但大多只是有趣的东西，更多的是那些越来越多地被用来衡量工作场所谁该做什么、谁最适合哪种职业、选择你想要在组织中晋升的人的东西。这是剔除各种多样性的好方法。不久前在加拿大有一家公司，发生了一次重大收购，首席执行官给每个被收购的人都做了迈尔斯-布里格斯测试，然后解雇了所有不符合这种类型的人。天哪。这太可怕了。
Everyone who didn't match his type. Good grief. That's terrifying. Many personality researchers put greater stock in a test known as the Big Five. It measures things like how much you care about the opinions of others versus your own judgment. It also measures qualities such as introversion and extroversion. At first glance, there are similarities between this test and the Myers-Briggs and other personality tests. But Adam says the Big Five has large amounts of peer-review data to back it up. That data, he argues, makes for better predictions.
所有不符合他类型的人。天哪。这太可怕了。许多性格研究人员更看重一种被称为“大五人格”的测试。它测量诸如你有多在意他人的意见与你自己的判断相比。它还测量诸如内向和外向等品质。乍一看，这个测试与迈尔斯-布里格斯和其他性格测试之间有相似之处。但亚当说，“大五人格”有大量同行评审数据来支持它。他认为，这些数据能做出更好的预测。
And what you're saying is that scores on this Big Five personality test do what compared to the Myers-Briggs. We can predict your job performance, your effectiveness in a team with different collaborators, your likelihood of sticking around in a job versus leaving, as well as your probability of your marriage surviving, depending on the personality fit between you and your spouse. But Alan Hammer, the psychologist who's a proponent of the Myers-Briggs test, disagrees with Adam. He believes the Myers Breaks is as reliable as other personality tests, and he says that Adam's wrong when it comes to the evidence that the Myers Breaks cannot predict real-world outcomes.
你所说的是，与迈尔斯-布里格斯相比，“大五人格”测试的分数能做什么。我们可以预测你的工作表现、你在不同合作者团队中的效率、你留在工作岗位而不是离开的可能性，以及你的婚姻存续的概率，取决于你和配偶之间的性格契合度。但艾伦·哈默，作为迈尔斯-布里格斯测试支持者的心理学家，不同意亚当的观点。他认为迈尔斯-布里格斯和其他性格测试一样可靠，他说亚当在迈尔斯-布里格斯不能预测现实世界结果的证据方面是错误的。
When people matched roommates on their psychological type, they got a 65% decrease in requests for roommate changes. Where Alan agrees with Adam is that the Myers Breaks is often used in ways it should not be used. The people who go through the certification programs learn how not to do this, but yes, this instrument as well as any instrument is misused, that's true. The Myers-Briggs Foundation has an ethics statement for the MBTI. That statement says, although there are many useful applications of the MBTI assessment in the workplace, there are ethical concerns in using it for hiring purposes. Again, Alan Hammer. I don't think the MBTI should ever be used to either select people into
当人们根据心理类型匹配室友时，他们对室友更换请求的减少了65%。艾伦同意亚当的地方是，迈尔斯-布里格斯经常以不应该使用的方式被使用。那些通过认证项目的人学习如何不这样做，但是的，这个工具以及任何工具都被滥用了，这是真的。迈尔斯-布里格斯基金会有一个针对MBTI的道德声明。该声明说，尽管MBTI评估在工作场所有许多有用的应用，但在招聘目的中使用它存在道德问题。再次是艾伦·哈默。我不认为MBTI应该被用于选择人进入
an occupation or to promote them. And I've worked in large corporations for, with large corporations for the past, I guess, 25 years. And we've never, ever used it that way. I hear what Alan is saying, but I would argue that these tests are popular precisely because they've purported to give us a quick snapshot of who someone is and what they're good at.
一个职业或晋升他们。而且我在大公司工作了，我想是25年。我们从来没有那样使用过它。我听到了艾伦在说什么，但我会争辩说，这些测试之所以受欢迎，正是因为它们声称给我们提供了一个关于某人是谁以及他们擅长什么的快速快照。
If you're a manager and you learn one of your employees is an introvert according to the test, it's absurd to think this won't shape the way you decide whether that employee should have a public facing role. Back at the Harry Potter conference, I start by a panel discussion. It was called Hogwarts Houses as Personality Ty types. It was packed, standing room only. People were even sitting in the aisles. The panel leader, Jessica Comstock, was listing off the personality traits that made people suited for each of the different houses. The people who are extroverts, are people who like to be the center of attention,
如果你是一名经理，并且根据测试得知你的一名员工是内向的，认为这不会影响你决定该员工是否应该担任面向公众的角色，那是荒谬的。回到哈利·波特大会，我开始参加一个小组讨论。它被称为“作为性格类型的霍格沃茨学院”。它挤满了人，只有站立空间。人们甚至坐在过道里。小组负责人杰西卡·康斯托克正在列出使人们适合不同学院的性格特征。外向的人，是喜欢成为关注中心的人，
people who like to have things go, go, go all the time, and people who recharge by being around others. Gryffindor's. Jessica is a self-described Harry Potter nerd. She spends much of her free time researching, analyzing and lecturing on various themes in the books. She saw a graphic on the internet one day that correlated Harry Potter characters to the Myers breaks. It was cute, but she felt misguided.
喜欢事情一直进行、进行、进行的人，以及通过与他人在一起而充电的人。格兰芬多。杰西卡是一个自称的哈利·波特书呆子。她把大部分空闲时间都花在研究、分析和讲授书中的各种主题上。有一天，她在互联网上看到一张图表，将哈利·波特角色与迈尔斯-布里格斯联系起来。它很可爱，但她觉得被误导了。
She thought the houses, rather than individual characters, made for a better correlation. How many people know their personality type? So Jessica designed a detailed chart to show how closely Hogwarts houses align with Myers-Briggs categories. I'm going to do a little experiment with the first few people. So what is your MBTI? Jessica looks at her chart. ISTP matches to Slytherin. What is your house? Yes, it is.
她认为学院，而不是个人角色，能做出更好的相关性。有多少人知道他们的性格类型？所以杰西卡设计了一张详细的图表，展示了霍格沃茨学院与迈尔斯-布里格斯类别的吻合程度。我要和前几个人做一个小实验。那么你的MBTI是什么？杰西卡看着她的图表。ISTP匹配斯莱特林。你的学院是什么？是的，确实是。
Somebody from another section, yellow. Said ESFJ or Hufflepuff. Right again, the audience sucks it in. And if anybody thinks I'm cheating, you're welcome to come and look at my notes. To the folks at Potterverse, the fact that there's a connection between being an ESFJ and a Hufflepuff is Proof that the Hogwarts houses are real signs. But as I sit and listen, I find Jessica's chart dumb-founding. If Harry Potter houses can replicate personality tests that companies are
来自另一个部门的人，黄色。说是ESFJ或赫奇帕奇。又对了，观众们全盘接受。如果有人认为我在作弊，欢迎来看我的笔记。对于Potterverse的粉丝来说，ESFJ和赫奇帕奇之间存在联系，这证明了霍格沃茨学院是真实的星座。但当我坐着倾听时，我发现杰西卡的图表令人震惊。如果哈利波特的学院可以复制公司用来决定员工录用或解雇的性格测试，正如我之前所说，天哪。
using to determine which employees get jobs or get fired, as I said earlier, good grief. By this point, you know where my head is at. I was disturbed by the multi-billion dollar industry that has been created around personality tests, but then as often happens, I heard a mind-bending story that made me think about these tests in a different way. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. We'll be right back. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. As I talked to Adam Grant about personality tests, I became convinced it was a terrible idea to use such tests to hire and fire people. But then, as we were reporting the story, I came across some research that made me think
到了这一点，你知道我的想法了。我曾对围绕性格测试建立的数十亿美元产业感到不安，但正如经常发生的那样，我听到了一个令人震撼的故事，让我以不同的方式思考这些测试。我是Shankar Vedantam。这是Hidden Brain。我们马上回来。这是NPR。这是Hidden Brain。我是Shankar Vedantam。当我与Adam Grant谈论性格测试时，我确信利用这些测试来雇佣和解雇员工是个糟糕的主意。但后来，在我们报道这个故事时，我偶然发现了一些研究，让我开始思考
about personality classifications in a different way. Now it's absolutely true that many personality tests are unscientific and unreliable. But does that mean they are useless? At Louisiana State University, the economist Nanji Mojjan was looking at how beliefs shape economic choices. His subject wasn't the Harry Potter sorting hat, but a more ancient way to classify personality. The Chinese zodiac. Our story begins in Anhui Province in China in 1987. A young Chinese couple had decided to start a family. Shao Qi and his wife Yang Shang were happily married and the timing was right. It was soon
以不同的方式思考性格分类。现在，许多性格测试确实是不科学且不可靠的。但这是否意味着它们毫无用处？在路易斯安那州立大学，经济学家Nanji Mojjan一直在研究信仰如何塑造经济选择。他的研究对象不是哈利波特的分类帽，而是一种更古老的性格分类方式。中国十二生肖。我们的故事始于1987年的中国安徽省。一对年轻的中国夫妇决定组建家庭。邵奇和他的妻子杨尚结婚幸福，时机正好。很快就
going to be 1988. As hundreds of millions of Chinese knew, this was a most significant year. After 11 years of rats and roosters and snakes and sheep, it was finally going to be the year of the dragon. According to Chinese tradition, there is no better year for a child to be born than the year of the dragon. Dragon kids are destined for greatness. Shaoqi was a doctor at one of the province's largest hospitals. He knew it was going to be a crazy year. Pregnant women were already pre-booking rooms at the hospital. Birds were going to skyrocket.
要到1988年了。正如数亿中国人所知，这是最重要的一年。在经历了11年的鼠、鸡、蛇和羊之后，终于要迎来龙年了。根据中国传统，没有比龙年更好的出生年份了。龙宝宝注定要成就伟大。邵奇是该省最大医院的一名医生。他知道这将是疯狂的一年。孕妇们已经在医院预订房间了。出生率将飙升。
It was the same across the country. It seemed that pregnant women were everywhere, dreaming of the greatness of their coming dragon babies. Shaoqi and Yangsheng lived in Huffay, a city with a famous history for producing brilliant minds and well-educated people. So when their son Han Yu arrived as planned in that most auspicious year, the already had big plans for him. Xiao Chi wanted Han Yu to be even better educated than himself, ideally at a top rank university in the United States.
全国各地都是如此。似乎到处都是孕妇，梦想着她们即将出生的龙宝宝的伟大。邵奇和杨胜住在合肥，这是一座以培养聪明才智和受过良好教育的人而闻名的城市。因此，当他们的儿子韩宇如期在那个最吉祥的年份到来时，他们已经为他制定了宏伟的计划。邵奇希望韩宇比他受过更好的教育，最好是在美国的一所顶尖大学。
And so, mother and father quickly instilled in the very young child, the conviction that great things were expected of him. This idea is kind of indoctrinating my mind, so when people ask me what I want to do, when I think about it, I really think that I want to be a PhD in the future, I want to be a doctor. That was the beginning of a long march. Hand recalls that when he was in middle school, his father came home one day at lunchtime, bearing an arm full of textbooks. And he just came back and knew one day and put some books in my bookcase and I asked him,
于是，父母很快就在年幼的孩子心中灌输了对他寄予厚望的信念。这个想法在某种程度上灌输到了我的脑海里，所以当人们问我想做什么时，当我思考它时，我真的认为我将来想成为一名博士，我想成为一名医生。那是漫长征程的开始。韩回忆说，他上初中时，父亲有一天午饭时间回到家，怀里抱着一大堆教科书。他有一天回来，把一些书放在我的书架上，我问他，
hey Dad, what did you buy? He told me that those are some textbooks for master degree students to practice their English. You know, at that time I was 13. Master's degree books for a 13-year-old. Shao Chi explained to Han that mastering English would be essential if he was to do well at that fancy university in America. He and Youngsheng spared their child from doing any household chores. All Han had to do was to achieve his parents' dreams. When I was at home, my father always said,
嘿，爸爸，你买了什么？他告诉我，那些是供硕士研究生练习英语的教科书。你知道，那时我才13岁。给13岁孩子看的硕士学位书。邵奇向韩解释说，如果他想在美国那所高级大学表现出色，掌握英语至关重要。他和杨胜让孩子免于做任何家务。韩唯一要做的就是实现父母的梦想。当我在家时，我父亲总是说，
Hey, son, I don't want you to do any housework at home. You just need to focus, perhaps that's not something right, but he said that we just need you to focus on study. Hand finished college in his master's degree in China, and then as planned, he went after the United States for even more education. Hand enrolled in an economics PhD program at Louisiana State University, where he met a mentor whose expectations of him were every bit as high as those of his own parents. My name is Najee Mojjan. I am a professor of economics at Louisiana State University and research associate of the National Bureau of Economic Research.
嘿，儿子，我不想让你在家里做任何家务。你只需要专注，也许这不太对，但他确实说我们只需要你专注于学习。韩在中国完成了大学和硕士学位，然后按计划前往美国接受更多的教育。韩在路易斯安那州立大学注册了经济学博士课程，在那里他遇到了一位导师，导师对他期望之高，丝毫不亚于他自己的父母。我叫Najee Mojjan。我是路易斯安那州立大学的经济学教授，也是国家经济研究局的研究助理。
Najee is Hans PhD advisor. When Hans told Najee about life in China, they talked about the Chinese zodiac and the power of the year of the dragon. They were sure that belief in the zodiac was just superstition. In fact, they were certain that anyone who was born in the year of the dragon would actually be at a great disadvantage. If there is half a million extra kids born in the year of the dragon, those kids will have more peers in the classrooms. There's going to be fewer resources per child in the schools.
Najee是韩的博士导师。当韩告诉Najee关于中国的生活时，他们谈到了中国十二生肖和龙年的力量。他们确信对生肖的信仰只是迷信。事实上，他们确信任何出生在龙年的人实际上都会处于巨大的劣势。如果龙年多出生了五十万个孩子，这些孩子在教室里会有更多的同龄人。学校里每个孩子的资源会更少。
The classrooms will be a little bit more crowded, etc. We would expect worse education outcomes rather than better. They decided to prove their hypothesis that dragon kids would fare worse than other kids at school. As it turned out, the Chinese government has a treasure trove of data. approve their hypothesis that dragon kids would fare worse than other kids at school. As it turned out, the Chinese government has a treasure trove of data, the academic performance of middle schoolers, demographic surveys, interviews with parents about their own education and household income, and so the two economists collected all the data, controlled for different variables, and crunched the numbers.
教室会更拥挤等等。我们预计教育成果会更差而不是更好。他们决定验证他们的假设，即龙宝宝在学校的表现会比其他孩子差。事实证明，中国政府拥有大量的数据。验证他们的假设，即龙宝宝在学校的表现会比其他孩子差。事实证明，中国政府拥有大量的数据，包括初中生的学业成绩、人口统计调查、关于父母自身教育和家庭收入的访谈，因此这两位经济学家收集了所有数据，控制了不同的变量，并进行了计算。
And they found that in middle school, dragon kids did better than their peers. They actually have higher test scores in middle school. These kids also outperformed their peers in high school. Even at this standardized nationwide University entrance exams, dragon kids score better. And they did better in college. Individuals who were born in the year of the dragon, they are 14% more likely to have earned at least a bachelor's degree. This was not the outcome that the economist expected to find. Yes, it was, it was really unexpected frankly.
他们发现，在初中，龙宝宝的表现比同龄人更好。他们的初中考试成绩实际上更高。这些孩子在高中也超过了同龄人。即使在标准化的全国大学入学考试中，龙宝宝的得分也更高。他们在大学里也表现得更好。出生在龙年的人，获得至少学士学位的可能性高出14%。这不是经济学家预期的结果。是的，确实，坦率地说，这非常出乎意料。
At first, Najee and Han came up with a straightforward explanation. Middle and high school teachers in China probably also believe in the zodiac. They were just granting high grades to dragon kids. But that account fell apart because college level entrance exams are graded by a computer, not by a superstitious human being. Also, dragon kids were outperforming peers in the same classroom,
起初，Najee和韩想出了一个简单的解释。中国的初中和高中老师可能也相信生肖。他们只是给了龙宝宝高分。但这种解释站不住脚，因为大学入学考试是由计算机评分的，而不是由迷信的人类评分的。此外，龙宝宝在同一个教室里表现优于同龄人，
kids who were born right before and right after the auspicious year. According to our results, it seems that when dragons compared with other zodiacs, average they are really doing better. Okay, dragon kids were doing better because they had higher self-esteem. So if everybody tells them, oh, you are superior, you are smarter than everybody, you are destined for greatness and good fortune, you know, they may believe that this is the case in their self-esteem, you know, we know that from other research that self-esteem is important in learning. People, kids who have more self-esteem,
那些出生在吉祥年份之前和之后的孩子。根据我们的结果，似乎当龙与其他生肖相比时，平均而言他们确实做得更好。好吧，龙宝宝表现更好是因为他们有更高的自尊心。所以如果每个人都告诉他们，哦，你很优越，你比别人聪明，你注定要成就伟大和好运，你知道，他们可能会相信事实确实如此，他们的自尊心，你知道，我们从其他研究中知道自尊心在学习中很重要。人们，有更多自尊心的孩子，
and they do better in school. But when they looked at how children reported their own beliefs about their IQ, there was no difference between dragon kids and kids born right before and right afterwards. And dragon kids are not more confident about their own abilities or about their own future. In fact, the Dragon Kids weren't really smarter. They scored the same on IQ tests. So what explained their success at school? Yeah, it's just the software basically.
他们在学校表现更好。但当他们观察孩子们如何报告自己对智商的看法时，龙宝宝和出生在之前及之后的孩子之间没有区别。龙宝宝对自己能力或未来的信心并没有更强。事实上，龙宝宝并没有更聪明。他们在智商测试中的得分相同。那么是什么解释了他们在学校的成功呢？是的，基本上就是软件。
Every Chinese uses this, uses this thing. From his office at Louisiana State University, Han Yu calls his parents in China. He's actually in China. calls his parents in China. It turns out the success of dragon babies doesn't lie with the schools or the teachers or even with the kids themselves. It's because of parents like Shao Qi and Yang Shen. From the moment Han was born, his parents had sky high expectations for him. That turns out to be the case with many parents of dragon babies.
每个中国人都使用这个，使用这个东西。在路易斯安那州立大学的办公室里，韩宇给中国的父母打电话。他实际上在中国。给中国的父母打电话。事实证明，龙宝宝的成功不在于学校、老师，甚至不在于孩子自己。这是因为像邵奇和杨胜这样的父母。从韩出生的那一刻起，他的父母就对他寄予了极高的期望。事实证明，许多龙宝宝的父母都是这样。
The parents of these dragon children, they are actually more likely to believe in comparison to other parents, that their children will obtain at least a high school education, at least a college degree, and Dragon parents are more likely to believe that their children will become a leader in professional life in the future. So, Dragon parents are different from other parents in the way they sort of believe in their kids' future. These beliefs become a self-fulfilling prophecy. Parents who believe their kids are destined for greatness, act in ways that help their kids achieve greatness. Hands' parents pushed him, giving him master's level textbooks
这些龙宝宝的父母，与其他父母相比，他们实际上更有可能相信他们的孩子将至少获得高中教育，至少获得大学学位，而且龙父母更有可能相信他们的孩子将来会成为职业生活中的领导者。所以，龙父母在某种程度上相信孩子未来的方式与其他父母不同。这些信念变成了自我实现的预言。相信孩子注定要成就伟大的父母，会以帮助孩子实现伟大的方式行事。韩的父母推动他，给他硕士水平的教科书，
in middle school, and telling him as a toddler that his goal in life was to get a PhD in America. As hand chatted with his parents, I asked if he could get a PhD in America. As hand-chatted with his parents, I asked if he could translate a question for me. Could you ask your parents whether they think that your success is partly because you were born in the year of the dragon? He said that during those years when I grew up, perhaps this also affects potentially affect their behaviors, their invest on me.
在初中时，并在他蹒跚学步时告诉他，他的人生目标是在美国获得博士学位。当韩与父母聊天时，我问他是否能为我翻译一个问题。你能问问你的父母，他们是否认为你的成功部分是因为你出生在龙年吗？他说，在我成长的那些年里，也许这也影响了，潜在地影响了他们的行为，他们对我的投资。
Hand-Zone parents, in other words, were the living embodiment of the research that hand was doing. Life had folded back on itself. Here was hand in America, getting his doctorate and publishing research about dragon kids that validated his parents' belief in his own dragon potential.
换句话说，韩自己的父母就是韩正在研究的研究的活生生的体现。生活又回到了原点。韩在美国攻读博士学位，并发表了关于龙宝宝的研究，验证了他父母对他龙潜力的信念。
And could you ask him then what is his reaction or feeling upon seeing that that dream has come true? Then, they want me to ask you, then you feel your dream has come true, what do you feel? You are not completely true in your dream.有什么感想在日本不能夠繼續生動 achievements, accomplishment, accomplishment, and also he expects me to have to continue a study in the US. So I guess for me it's going to be a post-doc. Yeah. Well, I guess I'll work harder.
你能问问他，看到梦想成真，他的反应或感受是什么吗？然后，他们想让我问你，那么你觉得你的梦想成真了，你感觉如何？你的梦想并没有完全实现。有什么感想？不能继续生动，成就，成就，成就，而且他也希望我继续在美国学习。所以我猜对我来说，这将是博士后。是的。好吧，我想我会更努力工作。
I don't want my parents to... I don't want to let them down, I think. And to get a post on a good, better university is also my dream. So... So yeah. Tests that propose to tell you who you are are nonsense... ...until they're not. That brings us back to Harry Potter.
我不想让我的父母……我想我不想让他们失望。在更好、更优秀的大学获得博士后职位也是我的梦想。所以……所以是的。声称能告诉你你是谁的测试是无稽之谈……直到它们不是。这把我们带回了哈利波特。
Jessica Comstock, the woman who connects Harry Potter houses with the Myers-Briggs test, tells me the story of Never Long Bottom. You're sneaking out again, aren't you? Now, never listen. We would... No! I won't let you! You'll get griffin' darns to trouble again.
杰西卡·康斯托克，那位将哈利波特学院与迈尔斯-布里格斯测试联系起来的女士，给我讲了纳威·隆巴顿的故事。你又溜出去了，不是吗？现在，纳威听着。我们会……不！我不会让你这么做的！你会让格兰芬多再次陷入麻烦的。
In Harry's year, you had a Neville Long Bottom, who actually turns out to be a really important character to the story. He starts off as kind of this bumbling weird kid. When it's Neville's turn with a sorting hat, it turns out the hat has a very hard time deciding where to put him. And Neville, the hat took, like, three minutes to figure out where to put him, which is a really long time considering that for some characters, the hat barely touches their hair and it knows. And Neville was almost a hat stall between Gryffindor and Hufflepuff,
在哈利的那一年，你有一个纳威·隆巴顿，他实际上成为了故事中一个非常重要的角色。他一开始就像个笨手笨脚的怪孩子。当轮到纳威戴上分类帽时，事实证明帽子很难决定把他放在哪里。纳威，帽子花了大约三分钟才弄清楚把他放在哪里，考虑到对于某些角色，帽子几乎刚碰到他们的头发就知道结果，这真的很长。纳威差点成了格兰芬多和赫奇帕奇之间的“分院帽难题”，
and Neville argued with the hat that he wanted Hufflepuff and the hat put him in Gryffindor. So the hat kind of listens to you, but if it depends on what your potential is, because it never grows to be one of the bravest characters in the books, and the hat knew that. And is that because the hat knew that or because the hat put Neville and Gryffindor and Neville learn to be brave as a result? That's magic. Does the hat put you because it knows you have the house or do you become the house that puts you in? Does the hat put you in the house in which you belong, or do you become the house the hat puts you in? Throughout our lives, we evaluate our children, our students, our friends and our colleagues. We enthusiastically look at tests that supposedly reveal the aptitudes and interests of others.
纳威和帽子争论说他想要赫奇帕奇，而帽子把他分到了格兰芬多。所以帽子会听你的，但这取决于你的潜力是什么，因为纳威成长为书中最高尚的角色之一，而帽子知道这一点。这是因为帽子知道这一点，还是因为帽子把纳威分到了格兰芬多，纳威因此学会了勇敢？那是魔法。帽子把你分进去是因为它知道你属于那个学院，还是因为你成为了帽子把你分进去的那个学院？在我们的一生中，我们评估我们的孩子、学生、朋友和同事。我们热情地查看那些据称揭示他人能力和兴趣的测试。
What isn't always clear to them or to us is the power of these expectations to transform people's lives. Sometimes our beliefs lift people up, make them run harder, reach for more. Other times our expectations attach lead and weights to wings, and keep dreams from taking flight. I can't say I have much confidence in personality tests, but I've come to understand there is huge power in the faith we have in them. Since this story first aired, Hanyu, having completed his PhD, is doing a postdoc at
对他们或我们来说，并不总是清楚的是这些期望改变人们生活的力量。有时我们的信念提升人们，让他们跑得更快，追求更多。另一些时候，我们的期望给翅膀加上了铅块，阻止梦想起飞。我不能说我对性格测试有太多信心，但我已经理解到，我们对它们的信仰有着巨大的力量。自从这个故事首次播出以来，韩宇在完成博士学位后，正在
Texas A&M University. We hope his parents are happy. This week's show was produced by Jenny Schmidt and Path Shock. It was edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Rainer Cohen, Laura Correll and Thomas Liu. We had original music in this episode by Ramteen Arabliwi. You can follow the show on Facebook and Twitter. If you liked this episode, please share it with a friend. I'm Shankar Vedantum, see you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
德州农工大学做博士后。我们希望他的父母很高兴。本周的节目由Jenny Schmidt和Path Shock制作。由Tara Boyle编辑。我们的团队包括Rainer Cohen、Laura Correll和Thomas Liu。本集有Ramteen Arabliwi的原创音乐。你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注该节目。如果你喜欢这一集，请与朋友分享。我是Shankar Vedantum，下周见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。